well guys we have made it this far in my
series of alien reviews leading up to
alien covenant we have talked about a
lot of movies and now we're going to
talk about alien versus Predator that's
right we're in the shit now I was such a
huge fan of this crossover as a kid I
love the comics I read some of the
novelization of course the Super
Nintendo game I adored the idea of my
two favorite aliens from my two favorite
alien movies at the time Alien and
Predator combining what a fantastic idea
and of course in predator 2 the greatest
Easter egg of all time when Danny Glover
is walking around that ship you can see
a xenomorph skull in the background and
ever since then fans went insane about
the idea and in 2004 we caught Paul WS
Anderson to finally direct it so that
happened I recall seeing this in
theaters and I remember everyone at the
time was so pissed off that it was pg-13
I honestly wasn't that bothered by it I
just found the rating reason hilarious
the fact that it actually says slime and
gore like slime is an actual reason for
why it's printed pg-13 kids don't watch
Nickelodeon there's a lot of time on
Nickelodeon it's bad for you
[Music]
so a VP takes place in the year 2004
what now if alien takes place in the
year twenty one twenty two and fifty
seven years later in aliens we are told
this we honed in on its beacon and found
something never recorded once in over
300 surveyed world if there's never been
any recorded history of xenomorphs how
did this take place in the year 2004 in
the future they have no idea what's
going on yeah yeah I know the AVP movies
aren't canon but not everybody who saw
this in 2004 knew that a lot of people
don't even know what the word canon
means in regards to literature or film
some people just go to these movies
thinking it's part of the same series to
make matters worse Lance Henriksen is in
this movie and plays mr. Weyland and
despite the fact that on IMDB he's
credited as Charles Bishop Weyland in
the film he's always mr. Weyland this is
the exact same actor who played the
Android Bishop and aliens and the human
counterpart of Bishop and alien 3 how
does all of this make any sense
it really doesn't right off the bat
we're kind of instantly confused if
you're paying attention to alien
chronology but you just have to accept
the fact that these movies aren't
related even though there are xenomorph
in them and predators they're just not
related guys beyond the idea of aliens
and predators fighting what I like about
this movie is the concept I love the
idea of this underground pyramid in the
middle of Antarctica it's a very
secluded isolated location it's a very
good idea because you can utilize the
use of a lot of really good sets you
don't have to travel too much and you
can do all of it and feel very
claustrophobic there's a great sense of
confinement and isolation in this movie
that's reflected very well in the use of
some really good set and it actually
does boost the suspense level I actually
like ADP more than alien resurrection if
I'm being brutally honest I don't hate
this movie at all I actually find a lot
of things to enjoy in it when Paul WS
Anderson directed event horizon I saw
that movie and I thought man this is
really reminiscent of the feel of Ridley
Scott's alien so the idea of him getting
to direct a movie with xenomorph it's
probably something he was pretty excited
about and when you watch this movie you
do get the sense that he is actually
trying like when I watch resident
evil final shots at us here I hated
everything about that movie even though
he was probably trying because it was
the last film of his baby franchise it
didn't seem like he was with a VP he
actually seems like he's trying to make
an OK film at least a watchable
enjoyable entertainment because you
don't go to these verses movies like
Freddy vs. Jason and expect Schindler's
List and they did an okay job at
presenting it and giving us them
actually semi fleshed out characters
they did make somewhat of an attempt to
make us like some of the heroes in this
movie it's not like today where they
just populate a movie with a bunch of
random cardboard people and monsters
come around and kill everybody they
actually did give an attempt to give us
reasons to care about these people like
the one scientist who has children at
home and he's creating a mini movie with
his camera for his kids I thought that
was a really great idea but at the same
time a VP falls back on a lot of the
same traditional horror cliches we've
come to expect at this point we have a
guy walking around a room getting
spooked by noises and since it's in the
middle of Antarctica they didn't have a
raccoon or a cat around so a penguin
popped out the setup for the movie is
just a bit bland I'll never forget
seeing this in oh for sitting next to my
one buddy and when the alien and the
predator finally start fighting I
remember him leaning over to me and
going finally I don't like I know it
takes a while to get to the action II
stuff leading up to them actually
fighting it's pretty much a
stereotypical bland movie where a bunch
of scientists are going someplace to
investigate something and there isn't
really any energy to it when John
McTiernan directed predator he made that
movie explode he gave so much vitality
to every shot in that film and when
Ridley Scott directed alien he made one
of the best suspense science-fiction
movies of all time these two things
coming together you think would be a lot
more fun and a navy pea it's just kind
of okay and disposable there isn't
really anything about this film that I
utterly hate because I didn't go into it
with mammoth expectations dude as a
title alone you go to a movie like this
expecting one specific thing these two
creatures to fight and anderson actually
directed the fight fine like they're not
great there's some high frame rate shaky
action every once in a while but it's
nowhere near as bad
his Resident Evil final chapter and I'll
be honest probably seeing his later
films after alien vs. predator and then
going back yesterday night and re
watching this movie that probably helped
me appreciate the direction here a
little bit more having seen what his
films have become since then in this
film you could tell that he was actually
still giving at least a semi amount of
effort to really try he did some shots
that directly tribute Ridley Scott's
alien like this shot of our hero
climbing up it's the same as the shot
and alien with Ripley climbing up from
the shaft but at the same time in
classic Paul WS Anderson style there's
so much flashing lights and random shit
that make no sense
like the Queen looks incredible but why
is there electricity everywhere like
what's going on in this scene why is
there visible electricity all around her
like what does that even mean let's talk
about the two title characters Alien and
Predator these things look really good
in this movie there is a surprising
amount of actual practical aliens I was
really excited about that when I
rewatched it because I didn't remember
it really anything about this movie
there are some very noticeable CG shots
but there's a lot of puppet work here
and of course the Predators all look
fantastic the whole design of this movie
the costumes the production all of that
is top-notch the characters in the
direction and the dialogue in particular
are really what suffer here the
directions find like it's excusable the
characters are also okay where the movie
kind of loses me is towards the end and
of course spoilers if you have not seen
AVP our main hero kind of teams up with
predator and they just kind of hunt the
xenomorph together I'm not really buying
that I feel like since what you learn in
the big exposition scene is that the
Predators are using the humans as a way
to hunt as we know morph I'm not really
seeing them teaming up they could I
don't really know everything about
predator mythology but I don't know it
just they didn't really sell it in the
movie it was so quick it was literally
like a minute and all of a sudden the
girl in the predator are just running
side by side and I just laughed out loud
when that happened and towards the end
it just gets really silly with what I
call Godzilla 98 Syndrome do you
remember in that film where all of our
principal care
in a taxicab somehow driving away from
Godzilla well in this movie our hero is
running away from the Queen alien and
the Queen is not catching up to her let
alone the fact that it's in the middle
of Antarctica and all she has on is one
layer and some pants and boots and she's
not even shivering I mean come on guys
surprisingly this movie is not complete
shit it's just kind of Hollow
it has no soul it's a movie that you can
watch that features Alien and Predator
it can be on in the background you can
pay attention to it every once in a
while and there's nothing in it as truly
awful as Alien Resurrection and that
newborn god I'm going to give a lien vs
predator a c+ nowhere near as bad as I
remember it being I think this movie got
a lot of hate initially because of the
pg-13 rating and I think a lot of people
were just ready to hate this movie from
the get-go it actually has a surprising
amount of gore for pg-13 next and
finally we're going to be talking about
AVP Requiem oh my god I can't wait and
then alien covenant which I actually
cannot wait for guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck my knives
[Music]